[موسيقى]
شكلت عمليات المقاومه الفرديه في فلسطين
في الاسابيع والايام الاخيره هاجسا امنيا
قد مضاجع قوات الاحتلال ومستوطنين ورفع
حاله التاهب لديهم الى اعلى درجاتها
العمليه الفرديه غير المتوقعه اصبحت تشكل
معضله لاسرائيل من حيث صعوبه التنبؤ
بزمانها ومكانها وشخوصها ولكونها رده فعل
انيه يبادر بها الشخص من تلقاء نفسه ردا
على جرائم الاحتلال وعدوانه ما يستحيل معه
امكانيه وقفها عمليات المقاومه الفرديه
بالاشهر الاخيره نفذها الشبان المنجيل لا
ينتمي لاي من التنظيمات والفصائل بحيث
نقلت الصراع الى مستوى جديد وفرض التحديات
المغايره على الاحتلال الاسرائيلي فما هي
الظروف والدوافع التي خلقت هذا النوع
المميز من العمليات وهل هي ظاهره ظرفيه ام
تطور نوعي سيشكل فارقا كبيرا في مستقبل
المقاومه اهلا بكم في هذه الحلقه من
سيناريوهات
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم بعد عمليتي سلوان ونبي يعقوب
في القدس المحتله مؤخرا وللتين او داتا
بحياه سبعه اشخاص وجرحت العديد من
الاسرائيليين باتت عمليات المقاومه
الفرديه التي غالبا ما ينفذها الشبان
الفلسطينيون في مقتبل العمر بعيدين عن
التنظيمات والفصائل وبدون ملفات امنيه لدى
الاحتلال باتت التحدي الابرز لحكومه
بنيامين نتنياهو المتطرفه واصبحت شغلها
الشاغل حول هذه العمليات الفرديه والى اي
مدن اصبحت ظاهره فعلا وتطورا نوعيا وما
التحديات التي تطرحها فلسطينيا واسرائيليا
يسعدنا ان يكون معنا في هذه الحلقه هنا في
الاستوديو معين الطاهر الكاتب والباحث
الفلسطيني من رام الله الدكتور بدر الاعرج
استاذ علم الاجتماع السياسي في جماعه
بيرزيت ومن الناصره محمد بركه رئيس لجنه
المتابعه العليا للجماهير العربيه داخل
الخط الاخضر فاهلا بهم جميعا
اكدت عمليتها انه في يعقوب وسلوان في
القدس المحتله ان جيلا جديدا للمقاومه
الفرديه بدا ربما في فرض نفسه على مشهد
الصرع هذا الصراع الذي تؤجزه حكومه
اسرائيليه متطرفه وفي ظل انقسام
الفلسطينيين فلسطيني لا افق قريبا
الانتهاء
فعلا يقابله رد فعل قلب خير علقم ومن عمق
القدس المحتله حسابات الثلاثي نتنياهو
بنجف
خريجه كنيس يهودي نفذ عمليه ادخلت اجهزه
الامن الاسرائيليه في ازمه وكابوس لن
ينتهي قريبه خيري الشب العشريني من شرق
القدس المحتله منفذ ما اسمته سلطات
الاحتلال اسوا هجوم منذ سنوات طويله وبلا
سجل امني لا ينتمي لاي تنظيم سياسي او
فصيل مسلح ولد في زمن قسم البيت الفلسطيني
ينتمي خير الذي اغتيل برصاص قوات الاحتلال
الى جيل فلسطيني يقاوم بمفرده ضد هدم
البيوت وتهويد القدس وتوسيع المستوطنات
وضد الانتهاكات المتكرره للمسجد الاقصى
المبارك وقبل كل شيء ضد السفك دماء
الفلسطينيين يحمل اسم جده خير علقم الذي
قتله مستوطن طعنا عام 98 في القدس المحتله
عمليه الكنيسه اليهودي من حيث التوقيت
جاءت مباشره بعد المجزره المروعه التي
ارتكبها جيش الاحتلال في جنين حتى قبل ان
تستوعب حكومه نتنياهو المتطرفه الصدمه
وقعت عمليه اطلاق النار قرب مستوطنه مدينه
داوود بحي سلوان اصيب مستوطنان بشروح منفذ
العمليه محمد عليوات الذي لا يتجاوز عمره
13 عاما هو من سكان سلوان بالبلده القديمه
من القدس المحتله يربك هذا النوع من
العمليات حسابات الاجهزه الامنيه
الاسرائيليه التي ترد في كل مره بهدم بيت
منفذ العمليه واعتقالي وترويع ذويه خلال
التحقيق نبته تعرف الانا بالمقاومه
الفرديه المستقله عن اي غطاء سياسي هي
مظله كل فلسطيني مهدد بالقتل والتهجير
القصري والاعتقال التعسفي وكل اشكال
الانتها ولد الجيل الجديد للصمود في زمن
السلطه الفلسطينيه بلا سلطات موعوده في
اتفاقيات مكتوبه على الورق ومن تشرذم داخل
البيت الواحد ومن بطش احتلال استيطاني
سياسات العقاب الجماعي والاستراتيجيات
الامنيه المتشدده لقوات الاحتلال
والتشريعات الحاليه والمنتظره بمباركه
الكنيست لسحب الاقامه من منفذي العمليات
والاسرى كلها اسباب تصعيد وارد ومنطقي من
الفلسطينيين في غياب مسار سلام حقيقي
لصفقه في خطابات السياسيين والدبلوماسيين
تحضر المواجهه غير المتكافئه ما قيل وسمع
من وزير الخارجيه الامريكي في القدس ورام
الله لن يغير شيئا في تعقيدات قضيه تعيش
الان مرحله حكومه اسرائيليه متطرفه جدا
باعتراف الاسرائيليين انفسهم جيل المقاومه
الفرديه يفرض تحديات مزدوجه وللمفارقه على
الاحتلال وعلى السلطه
عمليات المقاومه الفرديه ليست جديده انما
هي متجذره وظهرت مع بدايات الاحتلال
وتنقسم الى قسمين الاول عمليات فرديه
لاشخاص ذوي خلفيات تنظيميه وقد برز هذا
النوع خلال السنوات الاخيره النوع الاخر
عمليات فرديه ينفذها اشخاص ليس لهم اي
انتماء تنظيمي وهي التي اصبحت ظاهره في
الاشهر الاخيره فيما يناديه نستعرض ابرزها
[موسيقى]
سيد ما عندي طاهر اهلا وسهلا بك اهلا ما
الذي اوصل المقاومه الفلسطينيه الى هذا
النوع من العمليات هذه العمليات الفرديه
التي هي ربما كانت نادره في تاريخ
المقاومه الفلسطينيه يعني انا اظن ان
العمليات الفرديه او تلك التي يطلق عليها
الذئاب المنفرده سواء كانت طعم بالسكاكين
او عمليات دهس او عمليات اطلاق نار
هي
في ظاهرها عمليات فرديه ولكنها في الحقيقه
تعبير عن رده فعل مجتمعيه
بمعنى اخر ان المجتمع الفلسطيني قد ايقن
بعد اعوام من اتفاق اوسلو ومن محاولات
التسويه السياسيه وفي ظل انعدام لاي افق
للمفاوضات او للتسويه او للوصول الى حل
الدولتين قد ادرك المجتمع الفلسطيني
بكامله ان لديه يجب ان يكون لديه خيارات
اخرى ادوات اخرى والذي ادركها هو جيل من
الشباب لم يشهد الثوره الفلسطينيه
المعاصره لم يشهد لا النكبه ولا النكسه
ولم يشهد حتى اتفاق اوسلو هو الجيل الذي
ولد بعد هذه الاتفاقات ولكنه تيقن من ان
ضرب الاتفاقات والمفاوضات العبثيه وصمت
المجتمع الدولي على ما يجري في الارض
المحتله لابد من تغييره فلجا الى مثل هذا
النوع
جاءك افراد ولكنه تعبير عن اراده مجتمع
باكمله بدليل ان هذه العمليات تتواصل لا
يمر يوم الا ونشهد نوعا من هذه الانواع
ويحدث هنالك ابتكارات يعني ابداعات مختلفه
وجديده في نمط هذه العمليات التي تجري
ولكن الا تمثل خطر بمعنى ان يترك
عمليه ان تترك عمليه النضال والمقاومه
لشعب كامل تحت الاحتلال لمزاج افراد هنا
وهناك هل فيها ربما هذا هذه المجازفه يعني
لا اعتقد ذلك الحقيقه لسببين السبب الاول
انها لا تترك لمزاجهم هي تترك لتطور
الظروف وللمناخ العام السائد الذي يفرض
ذلك هذا المناخ العاقل العام السائد لا
يفرض فقط العمليات الفرديه في السابق مثلا
بعد نكسه حزيران فرض بروز الفصائل
الفلسطينيه بعد اتفاق خفت الى حد كبير صوت
الفصائل وصوت العمل المنظم وخصوصا في
الضفه الغربيه في ظل التنسيق الامني الذي
حدث ما بين السلطه الفلسطينيه وما بين
سلطات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي هذا بدوره لا
شك يعني الوضع لا يحتمل فراغ التاريخ لا
يحتمل فراغ لذلك كان لابد من ان تظهر
ظواهر اخرى جديده مختلفه تتمثل في هذه
العمليات كما حدث في الانتفاضه الاولى
الانتفاضه الاولى ظهرت كرده فعل شعبيه على
اطاله امد الاحتلال وقاوم في حينها الشعب
الفلسطيني بالحجاره وكان هذا هو اسلوبه في
الانتفاضه الان هذا الاسلوب اصبح اسلوب
يعني عام وظاهر ويومي لكن هل تتطور اشكال
اخرى بالتاكيد يمكن ان تتطور اشكال اخرى
بموازات هذا الاسلوب
الدكتور بدر الاعرج ما التحديات التي
يطرحها مثل هذا الاسلوب في العمليات
بالنسبه لي
سيروره المقاومه الفلسطينيه
التحدي الرئيسي هو عمليه
تاطير واستمراريه مثل هذه الهجمات لانه
عندما نتحدث عن الهجمات الفرديه لا نتحدث
فقط عن الموجه الحاليه موجه 2022 23 كان
لدينا موجه اخرى في عام 2015 2016 ولكن
تلك الموجه للاسف
هدات نسبيا في عوام 2017 لحد 2021
وبالتالي من اجل استمراريه مثل هذه
الهجمات يجب
تاطيرها ولا يمكن للهجمات الفرديه ان تشكل
بديل
لدور الاحزاب والقوى الوطنيه الفلسطينيه
يمكن لهذه الهجمات ان تكون مقدمه لمرحله
ما كما حصل في السابق مرحله ما قبل
الانتفاضه الاولى ومرحله ما قبل الانتفاضه
الثانيه لكن لا يمكن لها ان تشكل بديلا
وبالتالي يجب تطوير وتاطير مثل هذه
العمليات اذا يعني اردنا الانتقال الى
حاله نوعيه كفاحيه جديده ولكن عندما تتحدث
عن
ضروره ان لا تشكل بديل
يشير هذا باصبع الاتهام للتنظيمات التي
ربما لم تلبي او لم تكن في مستوى طموحات
هؤلاء الشباب فخرجوا عنها يعني لا نقول
تمردوا عنها او انشقوا عنها ولكن اصبحوا
يرون في الخلاص خلاصا على طريقتهم
لا اعتقد بان ذلك يشكل تمردا على الاحزاب
الفلسطينيه لان الكثير من هؤلاء الشباب
يعني لديهم خلفيات تنظيميه في في مثل هذه
الاحزاب ولكن كما هو معلوم منذ عام 2007
الساحه الفلسطينيه تعاني من انقسام سياسي
وهناك قوه فلسطينيه رئيسيه وفي مقدمتها
حركه فتح لديها
استراتيجيه تقوم على السلام
وبالتالي ذلك جميعه يؤثر ويخلق حالي من
الترهل في الساحه الفلسطينيه انا برايي
بانه الدافع الاساسي للقيام وراء هذه
العمليات بالنسبه لهؤلاء الشباب هو
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وجرائمه وجرائم قطعان
مستوطنيه فالاحتلال هو المحرض الرئيسي
لهؤلاء الشباب
يعني دون ما يكون هناك علاقه مباشره في
مساله الترهل الذي تعاني منه الاحزاب
الفلسطينيه لان هؤلاء الشباب يشعرون بان
حياتهم اصبحت رخيصه بنظر هذا الاحتلال
وبالتالي هم يريدون ان يبلغوا هذا
الاحتلال وقطع مستوطنيه بان حياتهم رخيصه
فان موطهم لن يكون رخيصا وسيكون له معنى
سيجعلهم يدفعون الثمن
وبالتالي يعني يجب رؤيه هذه العمليات ليست
كحوادث فرديه
مبعثره هنا وهناك ولكن كجزء من حال كفاحيه
نضاليه عامه
يعيشها الشعب الفلسطيني وهذه الحاله
الكفاحيه تعيش يعني احوال مد وجزر يعني هو
ليس سرا ادنا نعاني او نعيش مرحله جذر
الثوري في الضفه الغربيه لاسباب يعني حاول
التوضيح بعضا منها
بالنسبه لفلسطينيين داخل سيد محمد بركه
كيف تنظر الاوساط
الفلسطينيه في الداخل داخل الخط الاخضر
لمثل هذا النوع من العمليات
بدون ادنى شك هذه العمليات هي افراز لقمع
الاحتلال هي ليست قائمه بذاتها لذاتها
يعني ما في مقاومه لشيء لا يجوز مقاومته
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وجرائم لا تطال
الفصائل ولا تطائل للقيادات بالتحديد انما
تطالب الشعب الفلسطيني في كل طبقاته وكل
مستويات حياته تتطاول المراه العجوز على
الحاجز وتطال الطفل الذي يذهب الى المدرسه
وتطال الشباب بكرامتهم طلاب الجامعات لذلك
اذا اردنا ان ننظر الى هذه الظاهره يجب ان
ننظر ليس وجها لوجهه الى هذه الظاهره انما
هي في مواجهه ماذا في مواجهه في الطرف
الاخر من المعادله الطرف الاخر هو منسوب
القمع الذي تمارسه اسرائيل والجرائم التي
تمارسها الاسرائيل والمستوطنين ضد الشعب
الفلسطيني واضح تماما ان هذا الامر يستند
الى عوامل اخرى مثل يعني الوضع على الساحه
الفلسطينيه قضيه
الانقسام قضيه ربما
نشوء حاله من النخبويه السياسيه وليس من
المقاومه السياسيه الوضع في العالم العربي
وكل قضايا التطبيع والتخلي عن الشعب
الفلسطيني سواء من خلال الاتفاقيه التي
وقعت او الاتفاقيات التي بصدد التوقيع
واخرها ما رايناه اليوم من اساءه لوجدان
وضمير الشعب السوداني الشقيق والعظيم من
خلال حكم انتقالي مؤقت يستقبل وزير خارجيه
اسرائيل ويعلن انه يريد ان يتقدم في اتجاه
تطبيع العلاقات كل هذه الامور مجتمعه بدون
ادنى شك مع انسداد افق اي اي عمليه سياسيه
تقود بالضروره الى الى اشكال مختلفه من
المقاومه مما في ذلك الاعمال الفرديه او
العمليات الفرديه
ويجب القراءه على القراءه ان تكون صحيحه
ودقيقه بمعنى
ان لا ترى او ان لا ننجر وراء الحكم
الاسرائيلي او الاحكام الاسرائيليه في ان
يقولوا انه يعني هذولا ارهابيين وكذا وكذا
حتى انهم في احد المرات عندما كانت عمليات
الطعن بالسكاكين لشباب صغار 15 و14 16 سنه
سالوني في احدى الاذاعات الاسرائيليه
العبريه
ما الذي يحدث لهؤلاء الاولاد انا قلت لهم
ما الذي فعلتم انتم بهؤلاء الاولاد حتى
فقدوا طفولتهم وعفتهم ورغبتهم في الحياه
بمعنى يجب ان لا ننجر ولا وراء
الترمولوجيا وراء الاصطلاحات السياسيه
الاسرائيليه انما يجب ان نعيد النظر الى
مصدر مصدر كلها ما يحدث وهو تعاظم وتصعيد
جرائم الاحتلال والمستوطنين التي تطار
الشجر والانسان والحياه والمدرسه التعليم
والمراه والفلاح وكل مكونات الحياه لذلك
باعتقادي يجب بشكل عام عندما نناقش
ونحلل وانا حقيقه لست محللا يعني بكل
تواضع احترامي لزميلي انا اتي من مكان اخر
اللي هو قياده المجتمع الفلسطيني في
الداخل من خلال لجنه المتابعه العليا لكن
انا اريد ان الفت الانظار الى ضروره ان
نقرا ما الذي يحدث في الجهه المقابله
بمعنى ان هذه العمليات هي ليست امر معزول
عن واقع او معزول عن عن عن سياق معين انما
هي افراز لعنف واستشراس هذا العنف
الاحتلال
والجرائمه ومستوطنه هناك اشكال سيد معين
الطاهر ربما بالنسبه للسلطه الوطنيه
الفلسطينيه في التعامل مع هذا النوع بمعنى
انه عاده هي
تمتلك صوره شبه واضحه لما يمكن ان تقدم
عليه فصائل معينه فتح او حماس او الجهاد
وهناك التزامات للاسف عليها فيما يتعلق
بالتنسيق الامني ويحاولون احيانا اجهاض
بعد العمليات هذا النوع من العمليات صعب
ان لم يكن مستحيل اجهاضهم مسبقا عبر تنسيق
امني او غير تنسيق امني ما التحدي المطروح
بالنسبه للسلطه عندما تتعامل مع العمليات
الفرديه
الحقيقه الموضوع فيما يتعلق بالسلطه
الفلسطينيه مرتبط بالتزاماتها السلطه
الفلسطينيه في التزامات اوسلو في الرسائل
المتبادله ما بين ياسر عرفات واسحاق رابين
في خريطه الطريق تعهدت بانها
ستقوم بشكل او باخر
بالحفاظ على الامن الاسرائيلي وعلى
ملاحقه كل من يحاول المس بالامن
الاسرائيلي وتفكيك الخلايا التي رسمت في
حينه في في هذا بالخارج عن هذا الاتفاق او
الخلايا الارهابيه لذلك السلطه موقفها
واضح في ذلك لكن السؤال هل تستطيع ان تقوم
باجهاض مثل هذا العمل انا اشك بذلك لانه
لا يوجد ملفات امنيه لهذا الجيل من الشباب
قد تستطيع ان توجد بعض العمليات اذا مثلا
قال احد الافراد الذين ينوي تنفيذ هذه
العمليه قال يعني تحدث الى صديقه او وضع
شيء على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي قد
تستطيع ان تصل اليه السلطه وتقوم باجهاض
ذلك ولكن الحقيقه لا السلطه الفلسطينيه
ولا الاحتلال الاسرائيلي حتى الان نجح في
ذلك في يوم من الايام الرئيس محمود عباس
قال انه اصدر تعليماته للاجهزه الامن
الفلسطينيه لتفتيش حقائب طالبات المدارس
بعد ان عثر في حقيبه طال المدرسه على على
سكين وذلك في محاوله لطمانه الاسرائيليين
بان السلطه الفلسطينيه جاده في ملاحقه هذا
النمط من العمليات ولكن من الواضح مما
يجري ان هنالك فشل ذريع للسلطه الفلسطينيه
ولقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيليه في
يعني ملاحقه مثل هذا النوع من العمليه هل
تراها الدكتور بدر الاعرج هل هل تراها
محرجه للسلطه هذه المساله لانها لا تستطيع
ان تجهدها لا تستطيع ان تتعامل معها مسبقا
وفي نفس الوقت ستتحمل تبعاتها السياسيه
والدوليه في فيما بعد
انا اعتقد بان موقف السلطه الفلسطينيه من
الهجمات الفرديه الاخيره يختلف عن موقف
السلطه الفلسطينيه من الهجمات الفرديه
التي ظهرت في 2015-2016 والتي اشار لها
زميله الاستاذ معين
السلطه الان كما نعلم قامت بوقف التنسيق
الامني ونامل بان يكون ذلك قرارا
استراتيجيا وليس كما جرت العاده في السابق
وما تقوم به سلطات الاحتلال والمستوطنين
وكل ظروف السياسيه التي نعرفها وتشكل
الحكومه اليمنيه الجديده الى اخره اعتقد
بانه قد اثر في مواقف السلطه الفلسطينيه
الى حد ما الى حد ما وبالتالي لا اعتقد
بان هناك جهود منظمه من قبل الاجهزه
الامنيه الفلسطينيه لوقف مثل هذه العمليات
الفرديه لسبب اساسي
ذكر سابقا بان هذه العمليات تحصل بدوافع
فردانيه وبالتالي لا يمكن السيطره عليها
الا اذا تمكنت اجزاء امنيه بشكل عام من
الدخول الى نفوس هؤلاء الشباب وهذا شيء
مستحيل وبالتالي لا يمكن لاي اجهزه امنيه
مهما كانت ان توقف مثل هذه العمليات التي
يتحمل المسؤوليتها بدرجه اساسيه وبشكل كلي
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
بجرائمه ووحشيته وممارسات قطعان مستوطنين
طبعا السيد محمد بركه القدس وشعفات والقرى
المجاوره هي من اراضي المحتله عام 67 ولكن
القرب الجغرافي والتلاحم
والالتصاق
بفلسطين الداخل فلسطين 48 هل هذا سيكون له
انعكاس بالنسبه للمواطنين الفلسطينيين
داخل الخط الاخضر من اي التداعيات مثل هذا
النوع من العمليات
اولا اسمح لي ان اقول كلمه فيما يتعلق
بالتنسيق الامني فكره التنسيق الامني وجدت
من اجل ان توفير اجواء مناسبه لاستمرار
المفاوضات من اجل التوصل الى حل نهائي
لكن في غياب هذه المفاوضات وفي غياب اي
افق سياسي
في طوال السنوات المنصمه لا يوجد ولم يكن
اي مبرر لهذا التنسيق لا يعقل ان يتحول
الفلسطيني الى مقاول امن الى للاحتلال
الاسرائيلي يفترض ان تكون هنا ايضا
المعادله واضحه الشعب الفلسطيني وقيادته
في ناحيه واسرائيل واحتلالها في ناحيه
اخرى خلط الاوراق في غياب وجود مفاوضات
ترمي الى الوصول الى حل حل الدولتين او ما
الى ذلك حل تقرير المصير للشعب الفلسطيني
في غياب ذلك باعتقاد انه لا يوجد مبرر
الامر الاخر
هو موضوع السلطه السلطه هي جزء من اجل
تصريف امور مدنيه في المناطق التي احتلت
عام 67 لكن القياده السياسيه القياده
الوطنيه تبقى قياده منظمه التحرير
الفلسطينيه
ويجب اخت او اختصار دور السلطه على تصريف
الحياه المدنيه وكل ما يتعلق في القرار
السياسي والقرار الكفاحي وقرار المقاومه
يجب ان يكون في منظمه التحرير ولهذا للامر
غائب الى حد كبير الان فيما يتعلق بسؤال
حضرتك بالنسبه للقدس والضواحيها كما هو
معروف ان القدس جرى ضمها عام 67 الى
اسرائيل بقرار رسمي بمعنى عندما يجري
تعداد السكان في اسرائيل يشملون سكان
القدس فيها ايضا سكان الجولان نحن مليون
وسبعمئه الف مواطن فلسطيني غير القدس وغير
الجولان لكن من يقرا الاحصائيات الرسميه
بنشوف بنشوف انه احنا اثنين مليون هذا غير
صحيح
بفعل هذا القرار الذي اتخذته اسرائيل قرار
بقوه الاحتلال وضم القدس عمليا جرى فصل
القدس في السنوات الاخيره كليا عن الضفه
الغربيه
وابناء شعبنا في الضفه الغربيه وفي قطاع
غزه لا يستطيعون الوصول الى القدس
والقس تتعرض الى انتهاكات والى مقدساتها
الى انتهاكات كان اخرها اليوم في كنيسه
حبس المسيح في القدس عندما دخل احد
المستوطنين وحطم صلبان وحطم تماثيل وحتى
مقتنيات للكنيسه والاقتحامات اليوميه
للمسجد الاقصى المبارك في ظل هذا الواقع
والاستفراد في القدس راينا ان واجبنا نحن
ابناء الشعب الفلسطيني في الداخل ان نكون
الظهير للقدس وهذا ما نقوم به من خلال
هيئه تنسيق عليا بيننا نحن في لجنه
المتابعه العليا شؤون الفلسطينيه في
الداخل وبين الفعاليات الدينيه المرجعيات
الدينيه والسياسيه الوطنيه في مدينه القدس
ولذلك تلاحظون انه في كل مره يكون فيها
شيء من الاشكال المواجهه
وحمايه القدس ومقدساتها نكون نحن في صلب
الصوره بمعنى ان هنالك انعكاس دائم على
حياتنا في كل ما يتعلق في القدس وعلى
القدس فيما يتعلق هناك
العمليه الفرديه يعني بما انها غير متوقعه
من جانب الفلسطينيين اصبحت تشكل فعلا
معضله بالنسبه لاسرائيل من حيث صعوبه
التنبؤ باي من معطياتها ولهذا سلطت بعض
القنوات الاسرائيليه الضوء على مواصفاته
بالنزعه الفرديه المتحرره من القيود
الفصائليه في تنفيذ العمليات ضد الاهداف
الاسرائيليه
بمعر
[موسيقى]
الشيخ هذا ما في نمر
ته الخطاب الاسرائيلي الرسمي وتبارك اقطاب
الحكومه المتطرفه في كيل التهديد والوعيد
للمقاومين الفلسطينيين وعائلاتهم كذلك
نستعرض فيما يليه ابرز هذه التصريحات
الرد على الارهاب في القدس سيكون قويا
وسريعا ورقيقا باجراءات لتعزيز الاستيطان
واغلاق منازل منفذي الهجمات وهدمها ومنحي
تراخيص حمل السلاح للاسرائيليين
سنسعى الى تقديم مشروع قانون لاعدام
الفلسطينيين المدنيين بتنفيذ عمليات قتل
فيها اسرائيليون كما اريد من مواطني
اسرائيل ان يحملوا سلاحا ليدافع عن انفسهم
من اجل اقتلاع الارهاب يجب علينا طرد
عائلات المنفذي العمليات وهدم منازلهم
ومصادره ممتلكاتهم وتحويلها لضحايا
الارهاب يجب نقل امهات المنفذين باكيات في
حافلات والقائهن على معبر القنيطره الى
سوريا وسلام على اسرائيل السلطه
الفلسطينيه كيان النازي جديد معاد ويجب
دراسه تفكيكها وانهاء وجودها واتاحه
المجال لاقامه ادارات حكم ذاتي منفصله عن
بعضها في الضفه الغربيه كل مخرب يلحق
الاذى بالمدنيين او الجنود سيقدم للمحاكمه
او الى المقبره
سيد معين طاهر هذا التحدي غير مسبوق
بالنسبه لاسرائيل وعمليا من الصعب معالجته
امنيا بالاساليب العاديه ما الجديد الذي
قد يطرا على التعامل الاسرائيلي في هذا
الموضوع
التعامل الاسرائيلي في الحقيقه ليس مرتبطا
بالعمليات الفرديه بحد ذاتها هي قد تستخدم
بعض هذه العمليات كمبرر ولكن يعني كنا
نسمع في غمره الانتخابات الاسرائيليه حتى
في الحكومات السابقه احداث يعني تصريحات
كبيره مثل تلك التي اوردتها قبل قليل في
البرنامج الذي يحدث في الضفه الغربيه ان
الضفه يتم قدمها رويدا رويدا المنطقه جيم
التي تضم اكثر من 60% من اراضي الضفه
الغربيه اصبح عدد المستوطنين اليهود بها
اكثر من عدد العرب ويجري ويمنع العرب على
سبيل المثال من البناء فيها يتم محاوله
تهجيرهم
باول في الوقت الذي تقرر هذه الحكومه
الاسرائيليه كما استمعنا الى التصريحات
زياده العدد الاستيطان بل الامور اكثر من
ذلك انا اظن ان ما تحاول الحكومه
الاسرائيليه او ان هنالك راي يعني واسع في
اوساط اليمين الاسرائيلي يقول بانه حتى
وظيفه السلطه الفلسطينيه قد استنفذت وانه
لم يعد يعني لها مبرر من الوجود وهو ما
استمعنا اليه بالتصريح الاخير الذي تحدث
عن تفكيك السلطه الفلسطينيه واقامه
كنتونات مختلفه وفي الحقيقه الان المدن
الفلسطينيه هي عباره عن جزر منعزله عن
بعضها البعض هذه الحقيقه الموجوده الان
انا اظن انه يعني اصبح هنالك الان في
الارض الفلسطينيه المحتله كلها من نهرها
الى بحرها روايتان هنالك الروايه
الصهيونيه التي تقول ان اسرائيل هي ملك
لليهود وهنالك الروايه العربيه الفلسطينيه
الاسلاميه التي تقول ان فلسطين ملك
لابنائها العرب الفلسطينيين وان هذا صراع
سيمتد بوجود العمليات الفرديه بوجود اشكال
اخرى ربما اكثر تنظيما في المستقبل بوجود
قاعده ارتكاز للمقاومه في غزه على سبيل
المثال بوجود
اتجاه عربي شعبي واسع ضد التطبيع انا رايي
ان انه لا يمكن ان يحدث استقرار في
المنطقه دون تحقيق العداله للشعب
الفلسطيني عدد سكان الفلسطينيين في القدس
وفي القرى المجاوره تقريبا 400 الف
ويحملون هويه القدس والان هناك تهديد كبير
لهم من قبل هذه الحكومه حكومه بنيامين
نتنياهو تهديدات بسحب الهويه
هناك حتى من يطرح اخراجها الحاقه باراضي
السلطه الفلسطينيه كل هذه المنطقه يعني ما
الذي تنتظره من هذا الخوف الاسرائيلي من
هذه ال 400 الف السياسه الاسرائيليه فيما
يتعلق القدس حتى الان الحقيقه سياسه يعني
فشلت على الرغم من ان المواطن المقدسي على
سبيل المثال الطالب المقدسي او المواطن
المقدسي الذي يذهب للعمل بالخارج نتيجه
التضييق على ظروف العمل في الداخل اذا
تاخر عن العوده او رزق بابناء اخرين تقوم
السلطات الاسرائيليه بوضع عراقيل باتجاه
منحيه للقدس وذلك اتجاه كما ذكرت بان بعض
القرى الفلسطينيه او الضواحل موجوده
بالقدس يتم الحاقها بمناطق السلطه للتخفيف
من العدد لانهم حتى الان لم يستطيعوا رغم
بالمناسبه اكبر نسبه للتكاثر السكاني
الطبيعي بين اليهود هي موجوده في القدس
ومع ذلك لم يستطيعوا حتى الان
الاسرائيليين على الرغم من المستوطنات من
جبل ابو غنيم من حزام المستوطنات الذي
سيمتد من القدس حتى اريحا على الرغم من
ذلك كله لم يستطيعوا ان يحققوا مثل هذا
التفوق السكاني العددي في القدس لذلك هذه
الاجراءات ستبقى قائمه ستستمر تاخذ احيانا
شكل الابعاد تاخذ احيانا شكل الطرد
وتسني الان عند الحكومه الاسرائيليه
قوانين جديده يعني تقوم بهذا الاتجاه ومن
حيث مثلا ان الذي ابنه على سبيل المثال
يقوم بتنفيذ عمليه تطرد العائله باكملها
من القدس وهذا بالطبع يخالف على القوانين
حتى في القوانين الجنائيه يعني لهيك عن
انه هنالك احتلال لا يحمل انسان وزراء
انسان اخر ولكن هذه هي سياسه الاحتلال
الصهيوني ما اسوا ما الذي يتوقعه
الفلسطينيون سيد بدر الاعرج فيما يتعلق
هذا الاحتقان الاسرائيلي في الرد على هذا
النوع من العمليات
يعني السيناريو الاول هو اشتداد الهجمات
التي قد يكون بها المستوطنين الاسرائيليين
في الضفه الغربيه
وفي الحقيقه يعني هذه الهجمات هي متواصله
منذ فتره طويله قد يحصل هناك نوع من
التصعيد او بعض الاعمال النوعيه وهذا يعني
سيناريو متوقع لهذا جرى الدعوات في العديد
من المناطق الفلسطينيه لتشكيل لجان حراسي
لمواجهه هؤلاء المستوطنين
السيناريو الثاني المتوقع ايضا في ظل هذه
الحكومه اليمنيه
المتشدده ان يحصل نوع من التصعيد في طريقه
تعامل القوات القوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
مع مثل هذه الهجمات ومع المواطنين
الفلسطينيين بشكل عام وايضا مره اخرى
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يقوم يعني بالتعامل
بوحشيه شديده مع المواطنين الفلسطينيين
منذ عام 2015 حتى الان عمليات الاعدامات
الميدانيه التي يعتقد انها بعض هذه
العمليات جاءت رد عليها ما زالت متواصله
اذا كان اذا قام الفلسطيني
بمخالفه مروريه بالقرب من حاجز اسرائيلي
تكون العقوبه هي الاعدام وهذا يعني شيء
غير مسبوق وبالتالي يعني اعتقد ان الحلول
النوعيه قد تم تجريبها اسرائيليا قد يحصل
هناك تصعيد يعني في في درجه
الهجمه الاسرائيليه سواء من قبل
المستوطنين او من قبل قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي ليس اكثر اكثر ما يخيف
الاسرائيليين السيد محمد بركه ان هؤلاء من
حمله هويه القدس يستطيعون التنقل بحريه في
القدس وفي مناطق 48 هل هناك خشيه من ان
يشمل هذا الشك وهذه الريبه كل
فلسطينيين الداخل وبالتالي يصبح الجميع
محل وليس فقط سكان القدس او شعفاط او
القرى المجاوره
يعني هذا الهاجس يسكن المؤسسه الصهيونيه
على مدار عقود منذ النكبه وحتى اليوم هاجس
وجود هذه المجموعه الفلسطينيه في داخل
اسرائيل وحتى عندما ضموا القدس اضيف هذه
المجموعه السكانيه الكبيره التي تعد مئات
الالاف يعني قبل
مده عندما سئل بعض السياسيين والمفكرين
الاسرائيليين ما هو اكبر انجاز في تاريخ
اسرائيل وما هو اكبر اخفاق الكثيرون
اجمعوا ان اكبر اخفاق هو ابقاءنا نحن
الفلسطينيين في 48 في داخل الحدود اسرائيل
بمعنى نحن يعني لسنا فقط مشروع مقاومه
للفكر الصهيوني وللمشروع الصهيوني انما
نحن ايضا شهود على هويه هذا الوطن في يعني
اسرائيل تخطئ خطا جسيما عندما تعتقد انه
ما لا ينجز بالقوه ينجز بمزيد من القوه
هذه عقليه عصابه
مفهمه البشر في كل الكون ان العنصريه يمكن
ان تهزم ان الاحتلال يمكن ان يهزم لكن
الشعوب لا يمكن ان تهزم لا يمكن ان تزول
يمكن ان تتراجع يمكن ان تمر بازمه بمحنه
ولكن لا يمكن ان تزول هذه الحتميه
التاريخيه على ما يظهر ترفض هذه العصابه
استيعابها وللاسف الشديد علي ان اقول انه
طالما تشعر هذه المؤسسه الاسرائيليه بان
احتلالها مربح لها فهي قد تبالغ او تتوغل
او او في هذا في هذا التفكير انه يعني
تستطيع ان تثبت عزيمه الشعب الفلسطيني
وتغير وجهه الى الابد هذا امر غير غير
معقول الاحتلال بهذه العمليه بالمقاومه
بمختلف بالضغط الدولي
باداره العمل السياسي بشكل صحيح
باعتقادي انها يمكن ان توصل اسرائيل الى
عز ويجب ان تصل الى اسرائيل الى عزله خاصه
في ظل هذه الحكومه اللي عندها كل المقومات
التي تجيب على التعريف الكلاسيكي للفاشيه
عبر التاريخ وانا لا اريد ان اطيل في هذا
الموضوع لكن اعتقد ان المعركه الان هي على
ان تكون هذه الحكومه حكومه مارقه خارجه عن
القانون ومنبوذه على شاكله حكومه جنوب
افريقيا ايام الابرتايد العمليات الفرديه
سيد معين الطاهر الاخيره
اصابت مدنيين اسرائيليين بعضهم مستوطنين
وبعضهم قرب الكنيس هذا ربما اعاد بالنسبه
للبعض الحديث عن الاهداف الذي التي يجب ان
ان ان
تكون هدف بمعنى هل هي
اهداف عسكريه ام مدنيه ام ان الامر لا
يختلف بين عسكري ومدني بالنسبه للاسرائيلي
هل تعتقد بان ما مؤخرا من عمليه ربما قد
يعيد مره اخرى طرح قصه العسكري والمدني
وعدم عدم اصابه المدنيين وغيرهم من الجدال
الذي قد يعود احيانا
يعني انا الحقيقه ان هذا هذا الجدل يعني
جدل طبعا متواصل حتى منذ ايام الثوره
الفلسطينيه المسلحه في الخارج
ربما يمكنك ان تطبق ذلك في حالات القصف
الى اخره ولكن يعني ساورد مثلا على
العمليات علقم التي قام بها بمسدس
وقيل انها بالقرب من كنيسه اولا هي في
مستوطنه مستوطنه اقيمت على اراضي 1967 اذا
سرق احدهم منزلك واقام عليه كنيس
او مسجد او كنيسه او اي شيء هل يصبح لهذا
المكان قدسيه انا لا اعتقد ذلك لانه
بالاساس هذا مكان مسروق وانا اظن ان
فلسطين باسرها هي مسروقه لذلك ومن يقيم
بها هو مستوطن جاء ليحتل ضمن المنظومه
الكولنياليه لاحتلال فلسطين لكن بلا شك
مثلا احدى السيدات بالمناسبه قرب الكنيس
قالت عن علقم انه مر بها وقال لها انا لا
اقتل النساء
ومضى ولم يمسها بسوء وهذا دليل على يعني
نبل وسمو اخلاقه وانه يعني لم لم يعني كان
بامكانها ان يقتلها ومع ذلك لم يفعل ذلك
وخاطبها
وبالمناسبه اغلب هذا الجيل يتقن اللغه
العبريه يعني خاطبها وقال لها انا لا اقصد
النساء انا اعتقد ان مثل هذا الجدل عليه
ان ينظر اولا الى ما تقوم به الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي من طرد من تدمير من تهجير ما
تقوم به من التسليح المستوطنين ليصبحوا
جيش من قطع الاشجار الزيتون من يعني من كل
هذه الممارسات عليه ان يتجه اولا بهذا
الاتهام الى تلك الجهه سنقوم في نهايه هذه
الحلقه بجوله سريعه دقيقه تقريبا لكل ضيف
عما اذا كان برايه هذا النوع من العمليات
الفرديه له مستقبل وسيستمر الدكتور بدر
الاعرج
له مستقبل وسيتصاعد لكن هذا نوع من
العمليات ليس بديلا عن العمليات المنظمه
والجماعيه
سيد محمد بركه
اي مقاومه للاحتلال هي اشتقاق لعنف
الاحتلال والاحتلال هو الذي يتحمل
مسؤوليته طبعا نحن لا نريد ان نرى اي مدني
يقتل في اي مكان لكن
دم اي انسان سواء فلسطينيا او يهوديا هو
على عنق الاحتلال الاسرائيلي سيد معين
الطاهر يعني انا اعتقد الناس تتصاعد لانها
تعبير عن رفض المجتمع الفلسطيني لواقع
الاحتلال اما مساله انها ليست بديلا فهذا
ما ستحدده تطورات الظروف
وهل يتمكن يعني ينتج عن ذلك وعن هذا
الواقع المقام هل ينتج عنه اشكال جديده مو
اكثر تنظيما من المقاومه نعم هذه حتميه
تاريخيه هل تعتقد ان الفصائل الفلسطينيه
ربما لا اقول منزعجه ولكنها تريد ان تؤثر
هذا النوع من العمليات لانها في النهايه
تريد ان تراكم ارث معين نضالي وتستفيد منه
سياسيا هذا النوع من العمليات هو جيد ربما
للشعب الفلسطيني بعمومه ولكن ليس
مساله تراكميه لا لفتح ولا للجهاد
الاسلامي ولا لحماس ولا لغيرها يعني انا
اظن ان الفصائل تاتي وتذهب بان الفصائل
ليست قدرا على الشعب الفلسطيني طبعا بلا
شك هنالك فصائل لها دور ولها وجود ولكن
هنالك فصائل اخرى يعني
تكتفي بانها تبارك مثل هذه العمليات او
تنتقد او يعني او تصدر البيانات ولا تمثل
في الحقيقه جمهور كبير وواسع انا اظن ان
على الشعب الفلسطيني ان يخلق اشكالا
مختلفه من اشكال النضال الفلسطيني من
اشكاله التنظيميه من اشكاله الحركيه ما هو
هذا الشكل ما هي هذه الطبيعه هذه سيفرضها
طبيعه الظروف القادمه
لتقديرك لماذا ظلت سواء الحكومه
الاسرائيليه او الاداره الامريكيه تعالج
كل يجري معالجه امنيه صرفه حتى زياره
بلانكا الاخيره التهدئه
والتنسيق الامني وضروره الحوار بين
الاسرائيليين والقياده الفلسطينيه ولا احد
تجرا لطرح الموضوع من ناحيه سياسيه تتعلق
باحتلال وبضروره انهاء هذا الاحتلال يعني
السؤال جيد يلخص الموضوع باسره في الحقيقه
المجتمع الدولي وبعض النظام العربي الرسمي
يعتقد انه ما دام
السلطه الفلسطينيه قد قامت بتوقيع اتفاق
مع اسرائيل في القضيه الفلسطينيه بايطارها
العام قد تم حله
يزعج هذا المجتمع النظام الولايات المتحده
او المجتمع الغربي او النظام الرسمي
العربي ما يزعجه عندما تتوتر وتنفجر
الاحداث هو لا ياتي ليعالج
يهرعون جميعا ناتلوا يعالج جذر المشكله
وانما يعالج لاطفاء الحرائق وهنالك الان
ولا تجري سواء كان على المستوى الفلسطيني
او على المستوى العربي لاحلال الاقتصاد
مكان السياسه بمعنى يعني توفير ظروف
اقتصاديه افضل مقابل تاجيل الحديث عن اي
حل او عن اي تحقيق للعداله للشعب
الفلسطيني الى مدى قادم شكرا جزيلا لك سيد
معين الطاهر شكرا ايضا لضيفنا من رام الله
الدكتور بدر الاعرج لضيفنا من الناصره
محمد بركه شكرا لكم جميعا كالعاده ننتقل
الى تغريدات بشان موضوع هذه الحلقه ونبدا
بهذه التغريده للصحفي الفلسطيني محمد
حسونه يقول فيها بخصوص العدوان على جنين
الاكثر خشيه عند الاحتلال هو ان يتحول
الغضب الشعبي الى سلوك على الارض على شكل
عمليات فرديه او منظمه حيث يعجز وقتها
الاحتلال عن توقع الرد وشكله ومكانه اما
سيناريو الرد من غزه فهو الاقل تاثيرا
لانه محدود زمنيا وجغرافيا بل انه متوقع
على المستوى متوقع المستوى والنت
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي الكويتي الدكتور
عبد الله الشايجي غرد بدوره قائلا عقليه
القلعه الصهيونيه وتغطيه وضمان امريكا
تفوق قوه الاحتلال التقني على الجيوش
العربيه وتطبيع سته دولا عربيه كبيره
وصغيره وقديمه وحديثه لن يمنع مقاومه اخر
احتلالا لدوله الشاب خيري علقم قتل في
عمليه القدس سبعه اسرائيليين حتى جيل
الاطفال يقاوم طفل عمره 13 عاما جرح
مستوطنين في سلوان
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي الاردني ياسر
الزعاتره يقول يقول من بن غفير يتوحد
منفذي العمليات بالاعدام على كرسي كهربائي
وبرلمانه يصادق على سحب جنسيتهم واقامتهم
اذا كانوا من مناطق عام 48 او القدس ايها
القتل الاشقياء يقول هل سيحسب من يطلب
الشهاده حساب الاعدام فضلا عن جنسيه او
اقامه انتم طارئون هنا ونهايتكم مؤكده
بوعد الله ومنطق التاريخ ونختم بهذه
التغريده للدكتور صالح النعامي الباحث في
الشان الاسرائيلي يقول موجه العمليات في
القدس تظهر للحكومه الصهيونيه وقواعدها
الثمن الباهظه لمحاولاتها حسب الصراع مع
الشعب الفلسطيني عبر القوه قاده الحكومه
يعون انه لا توجد وصفه تضمن احباط
العمليات الفرديه وبالتالي فان اجراءاتهم
القمعيه ليس فقط لن تحقق الغرض بل ستؤجر
السيد بما لا يخدم مصالحهم
بهذا مشاهدينا الكرام نكون قد وصلنا الى
نهايه هذه الحلقه موعدنا يتجدد الاسبوع
المقبل باذن الله مع سيناريوهات جديده في
امان الله
[موسيقى]